Speaker 1: Melania Trump Not someone we typically
talk about, but she gave her first major interview
since leaving the White House as a failed
first lady. This is an interview on Fox
News that I have to tell you, North Korean
broadcasters who do North Korean state media,
they would see this and blush and go, this is too
fawning of an interview. You have to see this.
One of the big questions from Pete Hegseth
to Melania was Given how attractive you are
and saying successful in business, isn't it
biased that you haven't been on the cover of
People magazine? This is an interview, folks.
Speaker 2: Yes. How did you put up with the
constant criticism? The media take Vogue. For
example, five months into Joe Biden's president,
Joe Biden is on the cover. Kamala Harris
is on the cover before she's even sworn in.
Hillary Clinton was on the cover when she was
first lady. Right. Michelle was on the cover
three times yet. With your business background
and your fashion background and your beauty.
Never on the cover of Vogue.
Speaker 1: Why? I mean, is there a
more possible question that you could imagine
that the question is more fawning than.
Speaker 2: This double standard?
Speaker 5: They're biased
and. They have likes and dislikes. And it's
so obvious. And I think American people
and everyone see it. It was their decision
and I have much more important things to do.
Speaker 1: And we don't know what those things
are. But she apparently has more important
things to do. This is indistinguishable from
a scripted state media interview. She said she
she did enjoy living at the White House.
Speaker 5: I like Washington, D.C..
I know it operates completely different than
any other city, but I really like it there. And
I enjoyed living in the White House. To be first
lady of the United States was my greatest honor.
I think we achieved a lot in the four years.
Speaker 1: Can you think of anything Melania
achieved? I can't think of one single thing.
Speaker 5: Of Trump administration. I enjoyed
taking care of the White House. It was my home for
a while. I understood it. It is a people's house.
It was. It was a privilege to live there.
Speaker 1: And maybe it'll be your home again.
Speaker 5: Never say never.
Speaker 1: Right? Never say
never. She may be back. She took
the Fox and Friends interview
as an opportunity to promote her nfts,
which I still don't even understand
what they do or what they're for. And I
kind of know a little bit about this space,
and I have no clue what that what it's about.
Speaker 2: So you're using a new technology to
help raise the profile and fund these initiatives?
Speaker 5: I have been working on my NFT projects
since I left the White House. My NFT is they
are available on Melania Trump dot com and U.S.
memorabilia dot com. And now we have a few of the
NFT that they are minting on it. It's a national
park. Beautiful 3D animated pieces.
Speaker 1: It's hard to imagine
something more inspirational than a
3D animated Melania NFT, isn't it?
Speaker 5: And photos Trump. There
are pictures and animated videos
from our time in the White House and especially
the one that I created for Foster Care Month.
It's the rose, the mirror rose. Some of the
proceeds of the sale of NFT will go towards
education, providing education, opportunities
for foster care, children who are aging out of
foster system. Nearly 20,000 children are
aging out of foster care. A year. A year,
yes. And now we have 407,000 children in foster
care in America. In America today. So I will.
Speaker 1: What a hard hitting interview here.
And then lastly, she suggests her critics
maybe instead of criticizing her,
just help help foster kids. Okay.
Speaker 5: Well, people I see always criticize
me whatever I do. And I'm used to that.
I move forward and I'm here to help young
people. And that is the mission. And those people
who criticize me, I would encourage
them to help in their own community
or maybe join my Foster the Future initiative.
Speaker 1: There you go. So if you are criticizing
Melania instead, do something to help the foster
kids. What did we learn in this interview? I think
we learned about the technique of the completely
meaningless, worthless, pointless. Endless
softball interview that is within the scope
of what Peak Pete Hegseth on Fox News can do.
Again, you look at Chinese state media, you
look at Saudi state media, Russia today,
you look at North Koreans case DNA. They would
see this and go that. Oh, man, that's a little
too fawning even for us. We we at least pretend to
ask a real question. Pete Hegseth didn't. Bizarre
stuff. And there is Melania in case anybody
was sort of anxiously waiting to see what she
had to say. Now that she's out of the White House,
I hope that it was satisfying to hear from her.